wir menschen haben keinen freien willen
unsere entscheidungen werden manipuliert
von unbewussten signale forschende gehen
davon aus dass die handlungen der
menschen einem plan folgen der
ausserhalb unserer kontrolle liegt denn
bei einem experiment wurden hirnsignale
schon 300 millisekunden vor einer
entscheidung gemessen und eine neue
studie bestätigt das auf beeindruckende
art und weise das können sogar sieben
sekunden sein sind wir also marionetten
und wenn ja von wem werden wir
ferngesteuert die ergebnisse sind
absolut verblüffend klicks um science
and future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannendes heinz videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen es ist eine absolute
premiere am freitag um 19 uhr gibt es
hier ein ass beendete kurz aber ihr
könnt mir löcher in den bauch fragen bis
zum gehtnichtmehr hier auf klicks und
das beste exklusiv und nur während des
live streams gibt es mein tesla buch mit
persönlicher widmung wie das genau geht
erfahrt ihr dann den link gibt's hier
unter me in der video beschreibung und
im ersten angeboten kommentar schreibt
gerne jetzt schon fragen hier und das
video und merkt euch den livestream vor
ich freue mich auf euch sich impfen
lassen oder nicht mittagsschlaf machen
oder sport treiben kinder kriegen oder
nicht jeden tag fällen wir zahlreiche
entscheidungen dafür wegen wir ab und
analysieren wie die tragweite dieser
entscheidung ist dann entscheiden wir
uns entweder wir entscheiden uns um oder
wir halten an einer ursprünglichen idee
fest alles easy und ganz klar wie es
scheint doch genau an dieser
selbstverständlichkeit mit der wir
entscheidungen treffen haben manche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
große zweifel dazu der us
neurowissenschaftler john dylan haynes
man weiß generell dass menschen nicht
gut darin sind zu sagen warum sie sich
auf eine bestimmte art und weise
entschieden haben wir handeln oft
intuitiv ganz oft können wir gar nicht
die gründe angeben warum wir eine
entscheidung gefällt haben und selbst
wenn wir diese gründe angeben sind sie
oft falsch wie sich zeigt bereits in den
70er und 80er jahren gab es zu diesem
spannenden thema experimente ganz vorne
mit dabei der us hirnforscher benjamin
libet bekannt wurde er vor allem durch
das so genannte lippet experiment
hiermit wollte er demonstrieren dass wir
menschen keineswegs über einen freien
willen verfügen konkret analysierte er
dabei wie viel zeit zwischen einer
bewussten handlungs entscheidung und der
entsprechenden reaktionen des körpers
verstreichen und tatsächlich gibt es bis
heute kaum indizien die für den freien
willen der menschen sprechen viele
experimente zeigen sogar das gegenteil
dabei beschäftigen sich
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
genauso wie philosophin und philosophen
sehr intensiv mit dem thema doch eine
finale antwort auf dieses spektakuläre
rätsel steht bis heute aus die große
frage also wie frei oder nicht frei ist
der menschliche wille maza 84 das jahr
das limit experiments eine kleine
handbewegung löste quasi eine kleine
revolution aus oder eine große der
physiologe benjamin lebert hatte damals
ein experiment durchgeführt das bis
heute die hirnforschung zum freien
willen prägt seine gedanken zum thema
beschreibt er in seinem buch meint ein
zitat geeignete aktivitäten von
nervenzellen können gewiss den inhalt
oder sogar die existenz des subjektiven
erlebens beeinflussen unsere sinne also
beeinflussen unsere wahrnehmung das gilt
und das erleben wir konkret täglich aber
gilt auch das umgekehrte können unsere
bewussten absichten wirklich die
aktivitäten der nervenzellen beim
vollzug eines freien willens aktes
beeinflussen oder steuern die
versuchspersonen wurden damals
angehalten eine spontane handbewegung zu
machen und den zeitpunkt anzugeben zu
dem sie sich zu genau dieser handlung
entschieden hatten dazu hatten sie
jederzeit eine schnelllaufende uhr im
blick und waren somit in der lage den
moment der entscheidung ganz präzise zu
benennen den experimenten zufolge lag
dieser zeitpunkt der entscheidung etwa
200 millisekunden vor der bewegung
selbst allerdings konnte bereits eine
sekunde vor der handbewegung ein
rätselhaftes signal im hirn der
versuchspersonen gemessen werden das
sogenannte bereitschafts potenzial
bereits eine bis 1,5 sekunden vor der
bewegung begann dieses spiel typische
hirn signal bevor es dann anstieg und
mit der bewegung seinen höhepunkt
erreichte hatte das gehirn diese
handlung also schon viel früher
vorbereitet war die entscheidung die
hand zu heben also gar nicht unabhängig
vom bewusstsein der versuchspersonen
getroffen worden durch ganz andere
bereiche des gehirns ist das gefühl der
freien willens entscheidung eine
illusion genau so interpretierte
benjamin limit sein experiment und
zahlreiche andere wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler schlossen sich an
das experiment also schien zu beweisen
dass es unterbewusste prozesse sind die
zu unseren handlungen führen und eben
nicht wie angenommen das bewusste wollen
eine spektakuläre these bis heute 2004
äußerte sich beispielsweise der
max-planck- hirnforscher wolf singer
dazu und forderte wir sollten aufhören
von freiheit zu sprechen verschaltung
sind es die uns festlegen der britisch
deutsche hirnforscher john dylan haynes
fasste das experiment vom management
lippert in einem interview mit
deutschlandfunk kultur folgendermaßen
zusammen das ist natürlich paradox wie
kann es denn sein dass man gesund weiß
wie ich mich gleich entscheiden werden
noch bevor ich selber das gefühl habe
dass ich mich entschieden habe damit hat
er eines der wichtigsten experimente zur
erforschung der willensfreiheit im
gehirn begründet doch es gab und gibt
auch kritik am limit experiment und das
nicht zu knapp die zwei hauptsächlichen
kritikpunkte zum einen wird das heben
einer hand unter den versuchsbedingungen
lippitz nicht als eine echte
willensentscheidung gesehen zum anderen
sei der versuchsaufbau so angelegt dass
eine exakte zeitliche bestimmung einer
bewussten handlungsentscheidungen nicht
eindeutig zu bestimmen sei der deutsche
neurowissenschaftler gerald hüther sagt
dazu zitat das da 300 millisekunden
bevor ich auf irgendein knopf drücken
hund ein bereitschaftspolizei aufgebaut
wird das hat mit freien willen einfach
überhaupt nichts zu tun willensfreiheit
heißt doch ich entscheide mich jetzt
eine bestimmte sache zu machen das
können sie doch nur dann entscheiden
wenn sie auch wissen dass sie es
hinkriegen man kann sich doch nicht für
etwas entscheiden dass man gar nicht
hinkriegt und hirn technisch heißt das
wenn ich mich dazu entscheide einen
knopf zu drücken muss ich auch wissen
dass wenn ich dann sage knopf drücken
dass es auch geht bei knopf drücken
fällt das nicht so auf und genau das die
vergewisserung dass ich so etwas in der
lage bin sei das signal hinzu kommt
kritik am versuchsaufbau denn benjamin
lebert führte sein experiment lediglich
mit fünf versuchspersonen durch klar
scheint also als ein eindeutiger beweis
dafür dass unsere willensentscheidung
nicht frei sind kann das limit
experiment nicht gesehen werden doch der
beweis einer freien
entscheidungsfähigkeit steht noch genau
so aus im visier der
wissenschaftsgemeinde das
bereitschaftspolizei also diese paar
hundert millisekunden ist dieses
möglicherweise gar nicht direkt mit
unserer absicht zu handeln verknüpft
manche fachleute gehen davon aus dass es
sich hierbei eher um eine zufällige
fluktuation des neuronalen
hintergrundrauschen handelt doch offen
ist warum dieses signal dann immer
ausgerechnet vor einer entscheidung
auftritt wenn es wirklich zufällig wäre
müsste es da nicht auch mal fehlen am
berliner hennes lab hat man ein
experiment mit der funktionellen
magnetresonanztomographie fmrt gemacht
beim fmrt kann beobachtet werden wie
sich neuronen im gehirn sauerstoff aus
dem blut hohen sinkt der
sauerstoffgehalt im blut verändert sich
die magnetisierung und das kann man mit
der
magnetresonanztomographie sehen bei dem
experiment legt man also probanden in
die röhre und ließ sie entscheidungen
treffen konkret ob sie eine linke oder
eine rechte taste drücken nach etwas
übung waren die vorstellungen der lage
die entscheidung über zufällig mit 60
bis 70 prozent vorher zu sagen wow es
scheint also doch schon lange vorher in
unserem gehirn etwas zu geben was vor
der bewussten entscheidung entscheidet
was wir tun werden doch das sieben
sekunden vorher ist in diesem experiment
festgestellt worden doch es gibt
entwarnung in einem anderen experiment
wurde eine schleife eingebaut die ein
signal für eine um entscheidung endete
als das forschungsteam also sah dass
sich ein proband in eine bestimmte
richtung entscheiden würde wurde ihm ein
signal geben sich doch anders zu
entscheiden und in vielen fällen konnten
die probanden tatsächlich die
entscheidung nicht mehr korrigieren aber
sie konnten es in anderen fällen auch
sprich sie waren in seltenen fällen aber
sie waren in der lage die entscheidung
die vermeintlich schon vorher getroffen
worden aufzuhalten also wird vorher
offensichtlich eine entscheidung
vorbereitet und nicht fest getroffen und
wir sind in der lage diese vor
entscheidung zu korrigieren
wie bei einer reihe von dominosteinen
die stück für stück umfang können wir
den prozess aufhalten wenn wir einen
stein zum beispiel herausziehen trotzdem
das wirklich bahnbrechende ergebnis da
gibt es etwas das unsere
entscheidungsfreiheit einschränkt wow
schweizerische wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hatten erst im
vergangenen jahr 2020 analysiert ob
dieses potenzial mit signalen der
körperlichen eigenwahrnehmung verknüpft
sein könnte beispielsweise hirnwellen
die von der atmung oder dem herzschlag
beeinflusst werden falls ja würde dies
den zufälligen charakter des potenzials
stützen herauskam super spannende
ergebnisse dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
das alte muster unserer probanden war
systematisch mit ihren bewussten
bewegungen verknüpft das
bereitschaftspolizei reflektiert demnach
zumindest in teilen kortikale
verarbeitungsprozesse die mit der atmung
verknüpft sind die atmung beeinflusst
damit einen fundamentalen aspekte des
menschlichen bewusstseins und der
bewegungskontrolle das absichtliche
handeln heißt also dass kortikale
bereitschafts potenzial also dass in der
hirnrinde ist anders als der herzschlag
offensichtlich eng mit dem atemrhythmus
verknüpft es steht also somit nicht nur
mehr allein für unbewusste
vorbereitungen absichtlichen handels
stattdessen wird es sogar von
unbewussten körperlichen vorgängen
beeinflusst möglicherweise handelte sich
bei bereitschafts potenzial also nicht
um die direkte vorwegnahme unserer
entscheidung stattdessen könnte es auf
fluktuationen der neuronalen aktivität
zurück gehen die wiederum durch interne
körperliche prozesse wie die atmung
geprägt sind demnach könnte unser wille
also doch freier sein als gedacht nur
das timing unseres handelns könnte also
unter bewusst manipuliert werden dazu
heißt es von den schweizerischen
forschendem das könnte nur ein beispiel
dafür sein wie akte des freien willens
eine geisel von verschiedenen inneren
zuständen unseres körpers sind und von
der verarbeitung dieser zustände im
gehirn und das würde ja beim atmen
durchaus sinn machen dass wir wenn wir
viel luft haben eine andere entscheidung
treffen als wenn wir wenig luft haben
also loszulaufen oder eben nicht
loszulaufen klar ist jedenfalls in
diesem forschungsgebiet warten noch
viele überraschungen auf uns dazu der
hirnforscher john dylan haynes die
psychologie zeigt wiederholt und auch
die hirnforschung dass unsere
entscheidungen ganz anders passieren als
wir denken es gibt viele beispiele dafür
dass wir uns daran täuschen wie wir
unsere entscheidungen fällen allerdings
und das ist eine weitere einschränkung
entscheidungen die wir abwägen treffen
wir komplett anders ob wir heiraten
welchen beruf wir wählen welches
smartphone wir kaufen das überlegen wir
dann schon länger und ohne druck
weswegen hier auch ein solcher verlauf
noch nicht festgestellt werden konnte
jetzt aber spontane entscheidungen die
ihr vor schon hoffentlich unbewusst
getroffen habt klingt gleich hier auf
den link und merkt euch den livestream
vor also gleich kommt er hier das große
live aber mein erstes ask me everything
ich beantworte alle fragen und die ich
freue mich vor allem auf eure fragen
jetzt müsste der link da sein also hier
klicken schreibt mir gerne schon fragen
hier und das video also live und in
farbe am freitag den dritten 12.19 uhr
und noch etwas mein tesla buch gibt es
nur während des streams mit einer
persönlichen widmung für jeden und jede
also auf den link hier jetzt ist
hoffentlich wirklich da in der video
beschreibung oder im ersten angebunden
kommentar klicken bis dann bleibt dran